If you talk to a foreign policy expert,
military expert,
not somebody who spends their time
focusing on civil liberties but hardcore
foreign policy,
very often they'll tell you that the
first thing the next president has to do
is close the facility at Guantanamo Bay.
It has done an calculable damage to the
strength and security of the United
States and our reputation all around the
world to have torture,
to have people kidnapped by our
government,
which is what's called extraordinary
rendition,
to have the president and the people who
worked for the president saying in
effect,
the law doesn't apply to them when the
United States acts this way,
we lose our moral force.
And that has always been one of our
great sources of strength around the
world.
So you know,
there,
there are ways to protect the United
States that don't require trashing the
constitution.
It's not so much the individual rights
of the people who are detained at
Guantanamo Bay though that's important.
It's also the whole system of
constitutional checks and balances,
which is the key way we keep our
democracy working.
Uh,
when,
when you have a president and a congress
and the president,
especially who,
who wants to use their power,
you know,
it's not a surprise that after September
11th power flowed to the executive,
that often happens after crisis.
It often happens too much.
There's often an overreaction.
And then we kind of correct it.
And that's happened throughout the
country's history.
And it's not a surprise that there would
be that kind of power surge after
September 11th,
and the abuses by Bush and Cheney,
or not even necessarily the worst in the
country's history,
but what's different and very alarming
and really almost unheard of,
is their argument,
which is that this is not power that
President Bush has because of some
emergency.
It's not temporary.
It's not just because of the emergency
of fighting terrorism.
It's inherent.
They argue in the presidency.
They argued that the presidency has the
power of what Dick Cheney called
monarchical prerogatives of the kings,
which is basically the president.
Any president has the power of King
George as if we didn't fight a
revolution precisely to overcome that.
And,
uh,
you know,
it's the,
there's nothing more dangerous that this
administration has done.
Then the theory of presidential power
that they've pushed,
which left unchecked would change the
nature of life.
[inaudible].